foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is James page at the ftth council
meeting in Madrid I'm here with Crystal
sandstead who is the CEO of City carrier
bochuka Crystal thanks for coming and
talking to us
um we're talking a lot at this
conference about diversity within the
sector feels like we've been talking
about that for a little while are things
changing
things are changing and I'm from Sweden
in Sweden it's looking good real good
which it doesn't do in Europe but we are
on the way in the right direction
okay so I understand things are
different as well how are they different
and what can we learn from from what
you've been doing for for everywhere
else yeah in Europe you can say that
women are out of the business when they
are home with children taking care of
them in Sweden that part has been taken
care of from the society part so in
Sweden both men and women are home with
kids and the companies have a good
a position to do that
okay
um we hear from others that uh and
particularly may be thinking about our
own experience in the UK that maybe some
of the problem is just the image of the
sector that is male dominated and maybe
there just aren't enough women being
seen in doing that job do you do you
think that's uh there's an image issue
it definitely is because in Sweden 20
years ago when I started I was the only
women you could say it doesn't look like
that today in Sweden there are a lot of
women coming into the business and the
industry in Europe when you look at this
conference you can say there are a lot
of men here so it's quite different and
we're trying to get more women visible
because there are women here that are
doing
very good things and have technical
Parts I am CEO so it's it's it's coming
great and you're obviously here as part
of the women in fiber committee what
sort of things are you working on at the
moment what kind of initiatives are you
putting forward to try and continue the
good work that you've seen in Sweden we
have two to look into why women isn't in
the industry and doing anything for that
one part is that women doesn't get
educations like men and
the other parts
is a
the thing that women
are in the business and then go home and
are home with children and don't come
back basically
no okay so that's great uh thank you
um we're really hoping that I'm seeing
the continuation of the good work of the
committee and hopefully we'll be able to
continue to to see more of Europe start
to take on the good work that we've seen
in Sweden but thank you for coming and
explaining some of that to us thank you
very much
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]